we enlisted the help of the great chef
and new york times best-selling author
and queer ice star anthony perovski
who is
just
so beautiful on the inside and the
outside and he showed me around his
brooklyn and it was really incredible
please take a look at this tour
hey everybody i am here in the borough
of brooklyn and i'm about to be
taken on the foodie tour with a total
cutie it's anthony perovski and look he
has a brand new cookbook it's called
let's do dinner it's so nice to meet you
oh my gosh it's so nice to meet you is
this right is this where our love story
begins maybe polish restaurant today
you're gonna take me and start the tour
at christina's
why did you pick this place my family
comes from poland it was the first
language that i learned i went to polish
school every saturday i still strongly
identify with that part of me and i
lived in brooklyn for like eight plus
years and like this was my hood
let's go let's go let's go
can we talk about the food a little bit
yes okay i want you to tell me
everything first we have borsch polish
borsch is like a clear consummate and
then inside you have ushka which means
tiny ears so they're like baby pierogies
and they look like little tortellinis
so nice and tart you can taste the beets
okay i'm gonna try one of these go for
it beautiful so as you're tasting this
the meat is not your packaged ground
beef there's something about the grinder
that kind of turns it into almost like a
pate like consistency and it just melts
this is a very unique approach to the
meat as you're saying i also really want
to compliment you
on your shopping list for your cookbook
oh every ingredient resonated every
ingredient goes well together with let's
do dinner co-author mindy and i really
wanted to make sure like there are a lot
of ingredients that are repetitive but
it's like i love to have my pantry
staples and my things that are there so
when i go to the store it's i'm looking
for my protein i'm looking for a
vegetable or two and maybe an herb i
think for the home cook that's what we
need is an unintimidating road map to
confidence 100
so where are we going next it's called
peter pan and they put honey in some of
their glaze for their donuts i love all
things honey i put it on everything all
right shall we go to the next place
we have to have a tree it's also what
life is all about totally
[Music]
i'm not like the biggest red velvet fan
but their donut is fantastic blueberry
which they're very famous for nice
little pop of sweetness and then of
course your favorite the honey which one
do we want to try first the honey yeah
cheers
oh my god
i do taste the honey yeah
it's perfect it's the most ridiculous
thing i've ever seen i want to lick it
that's
like bringing me at that point
oh yeah yeah i just said it's nice i
mean it was good worth it i've been
trying to make a reservation at lilia's
for the past year and i haven't been
able to so i'm using your star power to
get it
to go have um a lunch after dessert
that's okay what's so crazy is missy
robbins is one of my idols
and i've never been to lillian so you
and i are gonna go be lilia de virginize
what do we try first we get to
experience this together as lily as
virgins that's right i think we should
try the oregano yeah okay
okay
cheers cheers
really nice heat oh that's lovely
our first
missy pasta
i'm so excited all right you're going
sun dried tomato right on there i'm
going pure cheers
i love saffron look at the saffron
bleeding into the butter the cheese is
sort of like a really gentle sheep
cheese the tomatoes are so nice and
sweet too
this one looks good pasta
like was on an award system this would
be the academy award and the espy's and
the golden and the can palm door
i just want to thank you because i've
come to new york my whole life but i
never felt truly at home here and now
this is really where i live so it means
a lot and i'm very grateful that you
would take me through this borough
and show me your city i also think when
i lay my head down on the pillow tonight
i'm gonna be going back to peter pan
donuts and christina are we all but in
all seriousness when you asked me to
show you a tour of brooklyn
like this was such an important place to
me
i always kind of look at my life as like
pre queer eye and post queer eye and as
grateful as i am i miss part of my old
life and to be able to like experience
it with somebody and like walk down that
street that i used to walk down on in a
way i've been able to kind of like
relive those feelings yeah so so nice to
do will you please take us out of this
segment in polish please because i love
when you speak out yesterday
brooklyn
thank you anthony i will never forget
that food that experience that awesome
deep talk we had and you can pick up his
cookbook let's do dinner right now and
you can get started with trying some of
anthony's recipes
everyone in our audience is going home
with a 200 gift card
courtesy of oxo
and
you can
pick up i know i love this company so
much
you can bake
you can pick up thoughtfully designed
cooking
tools storage organization i love this
company and i know you do already so
cheers oxo thank you
[Music]